ああああああ
me
goo
pareja rel
tee
ran
can you do
[拍手]
はいえー
改めましてこんにちは田畑集やと申しますよろしくお願いします
ああああああ
まず最初に皆さんにお伝えしておきたいことがありましてそれは僕はトロンボーンを
演奏できませんし
英語で話すこともできませんして後そうですね
すごいケーキを持ってたりすることもないんであの
休憩時間に
パッときたパフォーマンを見ている自分で見てくださると
とでも僕としてもすごいやりやすいんでハイ
その
気分でリラックスしてみていただきをお願いします
今
福井県に紹介していただいたんですけれども
あの月曜から柚花 c
毎週見ているよって言う
毎週見てるよという方いらっしゃいますか
レスですよねここに来る方はそんな
月やっぱりよくないしするような方じゃないと思っている
で僕を見たことあるって言うと燃えないとちょっと残念ですけどそうです
すっ
一応テレビにも出演させていただいてちょっとしゃべったんですけど
じゃあ本題に入らせていただい大失態と思います
僕はこの点まーすという趣味を中学1年生の時から始めまして
きっかけは youtube でペン回しの動画を見つけたことから始まりますそこ
からずっと今まで続けてきて今に至るかなという感じです
であるし
友達にちょっと始めたての頃ドヤ顔で
へまあ所してもしすごいだろう
見せたんですよえっ友達もやっぱり
すげーて言ってくれたんですけどその後何のためにペンますしてるっていう
疲れて
なるほどなと思って
確かに自分が何で顛末してるのかなんて考えたことなかったんでちょっと考えてみたら
やっぱり楽しいからという理由が一番だったんですね
でもうちょっとこの講演会のために考えてみたんですけど
それはやっぱり自分の人生のすごいなく哲学的なことになっちゃうけどてますから
自分の人生の価値を高めるっていうことにつながるかなと思っております
その
自分の人生を高める一つのツールとして趣味
誰にも負けない趣味っていうのがあると思っておりますので
装置と今日は1その一つの例として前ましょう
みなさんにも体験していただきたいなと思います
これから技を紹介しますのでぜひ皆さん4点持っていましたら御ペンでもなんでもいい
んで
どうぞ取り出していただいていけばあの
重心が偏ってないんですがいい
ふふっ
じゃあ紹介に行きたいと思います
天満署にはまず大きく分けて4つの基本技からでできていて一つ目はノーマル
何っとっ
ノーマルって言って親指の周りを一回転するわず
次に札びらソニック
この2つは
この2つを地下できるよって言うかた
そうですねすちらほらいらっしゃるんですねこのまずはこの2つの技は8
一般の方にもよく知られていて皆さん授業中とかにもやると思うんですけど今日今日
紹介するは the back around という技になります
こういう技です
高
こんな感じですねあと一つガンマンっていうの
元本っていう行為はぜなんですけど今日は室の一つのバックランドということを教え
たいと思います
じゃあ児童から説明したいと思います
まず構えは
このように
力を抜いて
まず人差し指と中指で点を挟んです
次に親指の間に変な事故
使うという感じでありますこのときにちょっと気をつけていただきたいのが
ペンの
こっちがこちらをちょっとな買って持っていただくとアップさせた後でちょっとまあし
やすくなるので
ぜひ意識していただいてお願いします
エコの形をこのままちょっと横にずらすこれが
カー日前になります
軌道を説明しますと
[ __ ]ミンセラーぬ
こんな感じで
人差し指のまわりを一回ですんですけどこの時に
ここ
人差し指と
中指の間をすり抜ける感じになるんですよ
人差し指の丸い改定してこう
いう形になります
で
骨として二つありまして
手首のこの動き
こういう感じの
えって来て縫っての動きで点を回転させると
この麦ともう一つは
中指を
こんな感じで
かぎ爪所いうかねえにしていただいて
ずっと中指はしたって思い続けて
意識していただくとことでちょっと後で二焼いたやりやすくなると思います
でこの全ての説明を合わせると
こういうふうに
一回転することができます
えーと今実際にやってみてできたよっていう人を言いますか
は口だけでは難しい部分がありますのでこの後の交流会の時間とか9検視官とかにあの
聞きに来て下されば実際に応戦することができるんであのう
僕が教えれば一瞬でできるんですよねはぁ
え
皆さんもねぜひ僕の特番にして
いただければなと思います
この
僕のこんな感じに地方馬座から
a
ちゃん基礎を鍛えて次につ応用をするというふうに連番しをしてきたんですけれども
趣味というの継続することでその効果を発揮すると思うんで
この声を僕の声を機械
機会に皆さんもあの誰も負けない趣味っていうのを探してみてはいかがかなと思います
はい
じゃあ最後にえーい
一番よく聞かれる質問が
一番10回しですごい技って何っていう質問なんですけど
ペン回しにもジャンルがありまして
5これが一番すごいって言える技がちょっとないんですね
これが一番すごい発揮いるはじゃないんですけども一般的にペン回し業界ですごい
神業と呼ばれている技を使用して僕の公園にさせていただきたいたいと思います
どんな技かといいますと
まず
親指を一回転します
その次に人差し指を一回転して中指薬指小指一回転します
ですさらに薬ウンジ中指人差し指親指と一回転
級会合気球回転する技になりますで上札がアルティメットファイナルインパクトと言い
ます
basa
皆さんもご想像の通りこの王座の創始者当時中学生しね
ではこの技を成功させて僕の講演とさせていただきたいと思いますのでぜひぜひ成功し
たら拍手の方お願いします成功じゃなくても温かい目で
あの chance をもう一度チャンスをお願いします
いきます
ろうかんでの寄せ
うぉぉー
[拍手]